It's Kansai, panda rya
ne
ran
[music]
It's gotten really bad, but I
don't care if it
comes in any
way.  It's up to the rebirth I
'm a
human being.
It's a
belly pack, and above all, what is the sweetness that seems to permeate deep inside
? The answer is this.
I rolled it up and chilled it. It's a little
bit
more flavorful.
Brown sugar
contains many minerals such as sodium iron, which is rarely found in ordinary
sugar, and has a unique
flavor.  It's fun to put a piece of fruit in each mouth and it bursts with a different flavor
Mature mother You can eat clouds, so if you enlarge it like this and put it on the bottom and taste the cake, it's even more
special
How many times have you traveled to dreamland
23 places?  When you say z to all the cuteness The
ginger that looks and tastes perfect is completed and the kingdom that she reigns
Tachihegoro is released to everyone Lovely and pretty bombardment type
[Applause]